GAME THREE IN GAME 4 HE STOPPED
55 OF 56 SHOTS.
BEFORE SAM REINHART THE ZONE.
>> Randy: THEY LIKE TO PLAY
PHYSICAL.
BUMPING THE PANTHERS BELONGS TO
PANTHERS .
PANTHERS  TRYING TO DENY THAT.
>> WE HAVE SEEN THIS NIGHTMARE
THROUGHOUT THIS SERIES.
WASHINGTON CAE PRESSURE. DISCOM
>> THE LEADERSHIP OF THE TEAM.
TRYING TO CLEAR AND HE DOES.
KICKED OUT
TWEEN.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE PANTHERS WILL
AND THE WASHINGTON CAPITALS
WITH SOME
GETTING IT ACROSS ICE.
TO CLAUDE GIROUX . BUT IT IS .
START OF THIS SERIES LOST IT AT
THE CENTER.  SUPPLYING THE MAJO
OFFENSE.
WHAT A HUGE GOAL.
THE CROSS. NICK JENSEN  .HIT .
BENNETT.
WAITING.
SENDING IT FRONT.IT.
AND CARTER VERHAEGHE
TONIGHT WITH A GOAL AND AN
ASSIST.THAT
HOCKEY PUCK.OSE HOCKEY PUCK IN
PANTHERS ZONE.
AND EETU  EETU LUOSTARINEN  COU
PLAY.
AND ON THE BACK CHECK, THE THE E
. AND HE HAS DOMINATED BACK.
THERE WAS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
KEEPING THAT GAP CLOSED.
THAT IS BEEN A REAL
>> IT.
4:15.